mother armenia stands tall overlooking
the capital yerevan
built in 1967 to replace a statue of
stalin she personifies the close ties of
the former soviet republics bound by
military might but as armenia celebrates
its 31st anniversary as an independent
nation
it's moving out of the orbit of russia
since 2018 in the revolution that took
place in republic square the
democratically elected government has
looked more to the eu and us for support
and while armenia still relies heavily
on russia and security matters it's a
reliance that makes many armenians
uncomfortable
i don't trust russians i don't know why
but i don't trust them because i feel
they take azerbaijan and turkey's side
continuously
i think relations with russia are in
trouble now and i think for armenia it
is better to take a european or american
position rather than stay linked with
russia
like this statue of lenin that used to
stand right at the center of republic
square most of the remnants of the
soviet era have already been removed
from modern armenia but russia remains
its main security ally particularly on
the contested border with azerbaijan
russian peacekeepers operate in the
disputed nagorno-karabakh region and
within armenia itself although they
failed to stop last week's border
fighting
the russian brokered peace process
however is increasingly being seen as a
hindrance and after the war in ukraine
moscow is no longer viewed as an
impartial ally
russia is a new challenge for armenia
the challenge is rooted in their role as
an unpredictable friend unreliable and
unpredictable hence armenia's necessity
to pivot westward just to seek more
balance in the relationship
as the statue of mother armenia watches
over the 31st anniversary of
independence she may be looking to new
horizons
as the sun sets on alliances of
armenia's past
tony chang al-jazeera yeruban